assalamu alaikum greetings of peace we
got a news flash for everybody
okay news flash world some exciting news
we want to send some love
stephen jackson my brother nothing but
love for you let me say that out
off the bat and congratulate him on the
most important and the best decision
he's ever made in his life
all right and stephen jackson now for
some of you wondering who's stephen
jackson
stephen jackson no the free throw missed
beatrix the rebound
within one a three is good
and captain jack drills the biggest shot
of the night
stephen jackson can comey bryant played
in the three or three and a half hours
he was a 14-year vet in the nba 14-year
nba vet my friend stephen jackson part
of the championship spurs in 2003
stephen jackson was also known for being
an honest and upright guy i was the guy
that had to be the vocal leader i was
the guy that the media came to after the
games because
as you know i'm going to answer honest
now what's this news this news is about
our brother
stephen jackson former nba champion
steven jackson who made the big change
in his life
as he officially reverted or converted
to islam
now just like you guys i was also very
excited to hear the amazing news
that there is none no none worthy of
worship
worth of worship except for allah
almighty
and i bear witness and testify and i
bear witness and testify
that prophet muhammed muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him
peace and blessing be upon him he's his
slave it's his life and his messenger
and his myth and the final messenger and
the final messenger with that brother
you know nba players make a lot of money
so if a lot of money
come a lot of prizes with a lot of money
come a lot of temptations with a lot of
money
the whole world opens up to you get paid
100 million
uh you don't have to play back-to-backs
you can rest when you want so when you
have this money we've seen that many
people they don't think
beyond the material things but he did
many people think they're going to live
forever
and they think this life is just about
plain amusement who can hit the most
jump shots who can score the most goals
now imagine coming to the basketball
court the basketball game and the
players are there but there wasn't a
clear objective there wasn't a goal
now what kind of game would that be now
imagine life everything is set in its
place
you're here i'm here we're living people
are dying but
there's no purpose now this is what
stephen jackson did he was asking those
questions i'm sure what's the purpose of
life why am i here
where am i going when i die and i can
guarantee you one thing if
islam didn't have all these answers to
the question that he was most definitely
thinking about asking like why am i here
what's the purpose
he would not have accepted it but it did
and that's why we're congratulating him
and sharing this good news with all of
you he's been known to play with some of
the greats kobe bryant
michael jackson i'm sorry actually
michael jordan he's had all the finer
things in life
he's been around some of the most famous
individuals some of the most influential
people he's been around stars
he's experienced the finer things of
life but now he's gotten to experience
something that money can't buy
with that brother
and that's what islam gives you because
you can have all these things
but of all these things you can never
get rid of the drama of life you can
never get out of the test of life and
many people are just living in the past
they might have been the michael jordans
of the world
but they're living in the past what are
you doing to set things right for your
future
okay your limited future in this life
that's okay but what about the future to
come
after this life so that's what islam
gives you it gives you a blueprint
for this life how you can be successful
what you need
what your purpose is what your ultimate
goal is and
it puts you on a direct path towards the
ultimate goal and the ultimate goal is
to pass the test of this life
and get to the real home called jenna
paradise
and to avoid the hellfire steven jackson
did something very courageous also
because he went against
all the negative hype and propaganda
that's pushed out there
calling people away from islam so he got
to see beyond that
beyond all the hype and he looked at the
evidence as i'm sure
he looked at the quran he read the quran
and now look
this is what brought him to islam now
you guys can learn from stephen jackson
he's brave he's not a coward
many people wish they could be in his
place but they're scared
they're worried about they're worried
about what their peers are going to say
they're worried about what
what people are going to say but that's
not stephen jackson he took that bold
step
he got past all the garbage that's put
out there against islam he got past all
the hate
and all the propaganda and all of the
distortions that are out there
he looked beyond that he went and he
investigated for himself and that's what
you should do also
look into this beautiful way of life
don't let others think for you
think for yourself evaluate it like he
did and inshaallah god willing
you can also come to that same decision
as he did that's based on proof and
evidence now i can go on and on and i
get very excited when i hear
news like this so i wanted to
congratulate our brother stephen jackson
congratulations my brother
with much love and much respect for you
making this bold decision
because i know for many it's not easy
but you're a brave individual you're
courageous you were seeking the guidance
and alhamdulillah the creator of the
heavens and earth he guided you
assalamu alaikum my brother inshallah
god willing we can have you here on the
dean's show sometime in the near future
may allah bless you the creator bless
you and continue to preserve you and
protect you
and make you someone who will help to
share this message
with all those people around the world
who are also in a state like you were
before islam where they don't know
anything about islam
all they know is the misinformation and
they're also
looking and seeking for more to life
purpose now it's our duty to go ahead
and do our part
to help to convey this message in the
best most respectful
honorable way that we can and for
everybody else out there subscribe if
you haven't already
you can go ahead and catch us here every
week on the dean show support us on our
patreon page we'll see you next time
until then
peace be with you assalamu alaikum